[Music]
all right joining us now with reaction
to all of today's major stories former
attorney for president from John
doubters with us young good to see you
thank you for being with us thank you
sure let me first go to the Woodward
book we now have you on record we have
general Kelly I think is four stars
right four yes general mattis's four
stars very impressive
he's very impressive all coming out in
the case of you what you said is you
want to be clear what is written in this
book about the so-called reenactment or
a mock interview of the special counsels
office you never refer to the president
as a liar did not say that he was likely
to end up in an orange jumpsuit that it
was an honor and a distinct privilege to
serve president Trump what do you what
does that mean to you is something that
you say is totally fabricated it is in
that book well that's what it is and
that's what it appears from testimony of
other people yeah and I assume that
bothers you well it does it's very
disturbing yeah it seems to be common
these days Shawn you were on Fox and
Friends and I saw the interview and you
said with all due respect you lost all
respect for Bob Muller he didn't keep
his word he should have declined this
case back in November of last year and
he's the one that asked for the
witnesses he's the one that asked for
the documents you know everybody told
the truth he told us he didn't need any
more documents here we are a year later
thoughts well I admit it I mean he it
was his it was his suggestion that
instead of that we ought to engage and
work together and we said fine you asked
for the you get to get document list ask
for your witnesses and Ty Cobb and Jay
and I provided them and and that he said
he wouldn't let any grass grow we in
every meeting and communication we had
we stressed how important it was and how
his inquiry was a great burden on the
president and interfered with the
president's ability to lead this country
particularly in foreign affairs and he
said he took that very seriously and on
and on he gave me his word he would do
it and we got to the late last year and
he had completed the 37 witnesses and I
asked him did you have any problem with
those witnesses they were all well
represented all well-prepared and he
said no did anyone lie to you no
documents we gave you 1.4 million but
more importantly we gave you the most
intimate notes of the communications and
deliberations by the president no
president history has ever done anything
like that are we missing anything did we
are there any missing documents no
you're satisfied with everything you've
got
yes well I said well what's what's the
president's exposure well the
president's exposure is he's a witness
slash subject I said so he's not a
target correct correct
that means he had no exposure and at
that point we said well why don't you
just decline he said well we'd like to
get back to you on that but we think we
need to talk to the president and I
raised the ESPY issue which we had
briefed thoroughly Jays people did a
magnificent job on the briefing on all
of those issues let me ask him and we
said we gotta get you got a what what
what do you not know that we have not
given you that only the president knows
and he could never answer that question
Sean and that's when I saw a stall going
on and I just lost complete faith in him
because we had shaken hands he's the one
that said John will engage we are once
we said we're not gonna raise conflicts
we're not gonna raise the legality to
the order we're not going to fool with
all this nonsense let's get the job done
this president wants the job done and by
the way the president gets the credit
he's the one that said give it to him
well John let me ask you this you gave
one point four million documents
and again the White House Council I was
shocked to hear he gave 30 hours of
testimony here you said he made this
promises but in retrospect looking at
the people that Muller hired all these
Democratic Clinton Obama donors Jeannie
represented the Clinton Foundation
Andrew Weissman who has an atrocious
track record do you do you now regret
believing him
I regret relying on him because he
didn't keep his word and I believed he
would keep his word
but more importantly the way we did it
completely protected the president we've
not waived executive privilege
we've not had four years of litigation
we've not had motions to quash grand
jury subpoenas we've not had anybody go
in the grand jury shot there is no case
there and that's what Bob ball are ought
to face up and do yeah so yeah it's it's
a very sad thing to see and then you see
the other cases I mean you see the Flynn
case of the and the other case and it's
just it's more of this sorry abusive
practice and the prosecutor Frank's now
powerful commentary Don doubt thank you
for being with us we appreciate it